I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning of every interview and with
directors and with writer directors I
like asking if you could get the
financing to make anything you want
tomorrow what's that project you would
love to make oh man well I have to say
this is not the most original answer but
it's one that I've thought about for a
long time and many great director have
chased and failed which is um Creature
from the Black Lagoon which I just
hugely influential movie to me it's also
like
you got to have the right take and I
actually kind of do have something like
I think that version of it could be kind
of interesting and could actually be
scary I think I think G Doro did shape
of water which is the more like the
Beauty and the Beast Mythos and it's
more the Romantic part of that what I
love about that story but I'm like G did
that so I can't I don't want to touch
his approach I'd have to like take a
different angle on on like what I love
about that franchise or that that movie
um but yeah that's a off the top of my
head that's one sure uh I read that back
in 2014 when you were doing the short
version of this you filmed it in
Michelle Branch's backyard this is true
and that's her cat too by the way right
so my question is how the F did you end
up in her backyard make the short film
uh so co-director of night swim Rod
blackhurst fellow filmmaker good friend
he was friends with her and I don't
exactly remember how but she just gra
she was like yeah like you can use our
pool
and I was like okay I guess we're
shooting at Michelle Branch's house now
all right cool so that that was that was
that simple just a friend of a friend
yeah it's definitely not anyway it's a
cool little tidbit it is a little tidbit
yeah so one of the things about horror
movies uh when I was a kid they when
when kids watch horror movies they can
affect you in real life for example
Poltergeist I refuse to look under my
bed for a very long time that clown yeah
God save us to totally messed me up so
I'm curious what did you see as a child
that actually or even recently that
actually affected you where you're like
yeah that's that's a permanent change in
real life okay so this is going to be a
very you will have already have guessed
this answer but it is the truth which is
I saw Jaws when I was 10
and could not go into the swimming pool
without that irrational feeling that
like yeah I can see the bottom until I
can't and when the lights go off now I'm
suddenly convinced that Jaws is under
there and it's rising up through the
fathoms to to drag me down like I just
was like something about Jaws and that
and the the water it didn't matter if it
was the ocean or if it was a pool it was
a bathtub it just like it just got in my
brain and I couldn't couldn't get it out
and so for me jaws was it was a huge
huge one yeah right uh you're not wrong
because it also affected me like no I
the ocean and I are not friends no you
know I've seen enough movies to know it
ends badly it isend badly no don't do it
and also this movie is going to affect a
how does it feel for you to have like a
new generation of like kids that are
going to watch this and be like I'm not
going in the pool do the dream come
true cuz maybe someone will be I mean I
dare I barely dare to dream that this
could be someone's Jaws because Jaws is
such a masterpiece but maybe to some
person it will do for the pool what Jaws
did for the ocean and that would be like
so fun because listen we should be
scared of the pool pool ain't safe so
I'm maybe I'm helping I'm helping people
you're you're the pool is not safe you
know all anyway that's
what do you think it is about the horror
genre and scary movies that people just
love coming back to them and they love
the genre well we don't have saber-tooth
tigers anymore and so we're not getting
hunted and killed on a daily bases by a
natural predator so but we have all
these built-in um systems in our
biological systems in our body like the
fight ORF flight and adrenaline release
that were bit to protect us we don't get
to use them anymore so I think horror is
like a beautiful way to tap into that
feeling of life or death and that
chemical release but you get to do it
with other people and you get to you're
safe and you don't actually get killed
in the theater but you have that it
simulates that feeling of like life or
death which we we don't really most of
us don't live in a life or death world
anymore some people still do sadly but
most of us don't so I think horror is
like a beautiful and communal way to tap
into that that feeling if someone for
hypothetically has not seen many horror
films uh scary movies what's like the
three off the top of your head that
you're like for the love of God watch
these okay let's go um there's a there's
a Japanese ghost film called Quon which
I love it's a little more obscure but
like it rules um let's go Society you SE
that which is also like a really messed
up bizarre kind of social commentary
body horror thing and then I mean if you
haven't seen the thing you obviously
have to see that um I'll also say like
the 1982 possession i' throw in there
I'm going a little off the beaten path
I'm assuming people have seen The
Shining I'm assuming people have seen
Jaws I'm assuming people have seen ringu
and other Classics so I'm going to I'm
taking us a little more into like
quieton possession Society uh territory
and night of the hunter I'd also say
night of the hunter not totally a true a
straight horror but horrific and hugely
influential to me 195 Robert Lon film
night of the hunter big plug I love
talking about the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
yes so you screen this for your friends
and family or blumhouse or whoever what
did you learn from those early
screenings that impacted the finished
film it was honestly just finding the
balance of
um the pace of of scares and when they
come and I think honestly for us it was
you're going to get such a pressure in
this type of movie to be like Trump
scare jump scare jump scare jump scare
jump scare and it's like there's jump
scares in this movie and I think there's
some good ones but I think it was
actually just owning the movie that we
wanted to make and that we shot which is
like it's buildup big scares but Slow
Burn tension to and creepy dread and
creepy mystery and sometimes like if you
don't force a jump scare let the movie
be let the movie breathe and I think in
editing that was um a real balance just
to find the trust in the movie Just to
trust the movie Let it breathe when it
wants to breathe and the scares are
going to hit even harder when they do
come that's my feeling so when I was
watching it last night I think I may
have noticed a few things in the
darkness in the background and so I'm
just curious how many things like that
should people be looking for yes and do
you want to give any teases as to maybe
where people should look so yes keep
your eyes open in the background of
the area surrounding the pool because we
kind you know that there's there's stuff
to look for also I have a cameo in the
movie in the deep water where we Face
the throng of the you know the the the
that that world I won't say too much
about it but um I'm a part of that
setpiece um and so you if you if you
look closely you can you could see also
that tidbit there I also would just say
listen
um there's certain there's a mythology
thing that I would say listen closely to
because there's kind of a setup for what
I want to do in the sequel if we get the
chance to do a sequel that's alluded to
by one of the side characters that is um
about the history of of oh yeah yeah
that I'm like that's where I'd like to
take the next installment um and I
wouldn't say I won't say more than that
I know exactly what you're talking about
listen uh great meeting you I really do
hope it's a huge hit for you and um have
a fantastic
day